the richness of the soft beet crispiness
of the brined pickled onions smooth
guacamole on the bottom makes the
perfect carnitas taco hi i'm chef
claudette zepeda wilkins and i am the
executive chef and partner of el jardin
in san diego california we have a fully
operational mini urban farm every day we
work very hard to make mexico proud
today we're making michoacan carnitas
carnitas literally translates to meat it
is traditionally made with pork that's
how we know it in mexico but you can
make amitas out of any meat in my
household we would eat it during special
occasions christmas thanksgiving diet
which is the first part of january so
you bring it up to a boil
and you can see a lot of these like
impurities what you would get in broth
come out of the meat it's just going to
give your end product more flavor so a
great starting point for so many other
mexican dishes the second day of
carnitas is perfect for making tamales
when you make tamales it's a very long
process and i remember as a kid there
was always the one thing that we would
forget you just look down and you're
like why do i have so many carnitas left
thankfully i come from a lot of really
funny women it results in a lot of
really bad jokes and pointing fingers on
whose fault it was we have veggies
it's fine veggie tamales are great too
we're going to continue to boil this
until half of the
liquid reduces and then we'll go to the
next step opening a restaurant is an
incredible challenge even harder when
you do something that people have in
their heads of what mexican food is
people think that yeah i'm insane for
importing a lot of my ingredients i like
to say that i'm making grandma style
food in a contemporary manner
now that is going to be used so it fries
the meat at the end you still have some
liquid in there and that's fine it'll
evaporate being a female chef is hard in
itself we have our fair amount of
obstacles this is a male industry being
a mom and being a chef the hardest
struggle internally comes from them the
most beautiful part of opening my
restaurant was having the kids there
this is my life my life is dedicated to
mexico my life is dedicated to my roots
our soil where we come from mother earth
always calls you back everyone has their
calling in life i've come to the
realization that this is mine i am
incredibly proud to be mexican and to be
the keeper of all of these beautiful
dishes we all have one commonality we
all have food
[Music]
hi guys are you hungry you have carmita
use your
hands excuse you
it's you
no
you sure yeah come on i'm the one with
the little arms that is a mess but it's
good it's delicious here you go ma'am
there you go man thank you ma'am
help well i'm glad i got to show
everyone how to make carnitas and now we
get to go and enjoy this on our own bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you